i see ralph's on the phone he's ready to
hand out the bobo punishment oh what
we're talking about here is bobo calls
me the other day and he starts in how he
wants out of the wack pack well i just
blew up at him and i said you know
you're so [ __ ] nuts all you ask me is
to be in the wack pack the whack pack
blah blah blah blah blah so i said you
know you don't deserve to be in the
whack back then he was like oh no no no
i want to be in the wack pack now so all
right it married it a punishment because
you got to set bobo straight i was going
to give him a little punishment but when
marianne called in and she started
challenging my manhood she was like
howard if you let bobo off what kind of
man are you
what do you make of the fact that
marianne is out for blood with you i
tell you howard we're really good
friends she's a sweetheart when it comes
to the show she speaks to mine and that
i can't be like that i i just have a
different way about it oh you phony
[ __ ] you gotta get yourself you
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god i'm gonna
[ __ ] keep it real boba when you're
the biggest phony on the planet but at
least no i'm not
i'm not a phone i'm a good guy
let me let me um
let me let me
let me let me bring some sense to
all right the only the only thing now
that is being punished is my eardrums
i've got to i've got to move on
bobo saved my ass and the way he goes i
don't care what my punishment is don't
let ralph make the punishment
so i said to myself this is good let
ralph come up with a reasonable
punishment i don't have to get involved
in this so now here is judge ralph
let's start with remember this howard
what bobo always does and what this call
was all about was him just trying to get
on the air he didn't want to get in or
out of the wack pass he's just looking
for a tent
good point
um so i'm thinking a few things this
should last three to six months right
first thing is
first thing is
he's
he's out of the backpack he needs to
remove all references from social media
he should have a new name it shouldn't
be bobo anymore no i'm not going through
that
[Music]
[ __ ] you i'm not doing this
he's to refer to himself as steve from
florida what is the name you want him to
use fools
from florida
and this is the most important and it's
actually more punishment to me but i'm
willing to do it he has to email me if
he wants to call in he's no longer
allowed to just call in because he goes
horribly wrong so i have to approve
whatever he's going to call it about you
will screen his call no listen to me
did i just die and go to hell with
heaven
by the end of the week by friday five
o'clock he's got to email me three
topics of what he wants to talk about
next week bobo open up your little
journal or your 20 journals of questions
for the howard stern show and run them
by ralph now and see which ones get
approved let's see if any of them get
updated
well here's one i mean this is a robin
question i was wondering throughout this
pandemic and robin had captain dennis as
simon simone dimmer dynastine over her
house provided they were vaccinated
thoughts
for that question
well bobo has to think after every
question so he wants you to think
ralph does that get approved
no simon
you're not being pertinent to the show
but one more this is a good question
howard do you uh on some level okay have
a concern when you do your painting
especially oldest pain centers the
vapors possibly go up into your nostrils
like the great part you know
nose
bobo that it's a bad question because i
do watercolor painting i don't use
chemicals like that that's for oil paint
but what do you clean your your your
watercolors with that the brush water
there's no quality control for these
questions like ralph could actually help
you bobo i think ralph will make you a
better performer yeah marianne you're
satisfied with the punishment
i need a drink
you